and this one selection
everything
okay so I want to talk about very new
work for us new so something we did in
the last half year in our group and so
junior people are gentle laugh and I'm
super mone Korean bellick
and then also robot Langston who talked
ready before then and we have a few
weeks ago we have put a preprint on
archive which sketches some of the
results about so two-thirds of what I
will discuss is ready
in this free print and so I want to
introduce a new version of spike neural
networks which we call LS and ends I
will have a short look at their
computation capabilities and then I come
back to the theme which might put Vinick
introduced yesterday enemy learning to
learn and so I will discuss not only
learning to that from robots but also
learning to learn from a teacher and
then a summary so I we have been working
on networks of spiking neurons in grads
for quite some time but now over the
years I got the impression maybe this
networks of spike neurons a little bit
dumb at least if you compare them with
artificial neural networks no particular
no record artificial neural networks as
you know know these networks have been
shown to be really powerful and I'm
talking here might talk only about
really recurrent neural networks and so
this was soon in a landmark paper know
from the Hinton group 2013 and that
normally substantial jump in speech
recognition capability can be achieved
with no but they call deeply cardinal
networks and then also know the state of
the art of speech translation for
example uses no Ricarda neural networks
but if you take a look closer look these
are not networks of the usual type of
recurrent sigmoid and neurons but
they're of lsdm units
and so I think at the moment even looks
at literature and artificial Ricarda
neural networks know almost all of them
if they re doing something remarkable
they have no lsdm units or some
variation of these then and so a network
of spiking neurons this has been lacking
and this may be one of the reasons you
know by one wasn't able to demonstrate
similar computational capabilities for
this networks of spiking neurons so just
you know micro reminder about this lsdm
units are so they were introduced by Ho
Chi Thanh Schmidt over 21 years ago and
I think roughly the ideas you want to
have in a Ricard neural network
something like a register in a computer
where you put something and then it
stays unperturbed until you want it then
and so this is actually not something
trivial but in a record neural networks
is difficult to achieve because know the
dynamics is working on this new cardinal
networks and all the units are not kind
of changing typically all the time then
and so this allows you to give you some
desirable stability no temporal
stability within a recurrent neural
network and so here you have therefore a
so-called memory cell and you can put in
there bit or number and it stays there
at the same value until you decide to
change it you let some input in or
there's a forget gate which kind of know
allows you to raise it or yes also you
can create an output out of the content
of this memory cell then and so all
these other knocks irrigates then these
are regular type sigmoidal gates know
they have weights then and when you
train lsdm networks and you train all
these no weights of these axillary gates
then and then looks at know the
state-of-the-art results and
computations with LSM networks is
actually not very large networks a few
hundred of this lsdm units are typically
already achieving or remarkable results
them
so but there's also no simply a
technical reason from the perspective of
optimization or learning by this I could
then because if you'd want to train a
network recording area network to back
propagation through time then you have
to virtually no unroll this recurrent
part so assuming these hidden ones are
currently connected now to do back
propagation you create a clone of the
same neuron set here for each time step
of the computation then and then all the
connections run from one time step to
the next time step there's no connection
within a time step so therefore you're
virtually kind of replaced this record
neural network by feed-forward neural
network which is as deep as the number
of time steps you're considering here
then and so then when you do back prop
for such network you do really back prop
know in this node then deep feed-forward
neural networks there and so therefore
if you have here now for example unit
here which is connected to itself with
the weight W and then here you encounter
no product no of this W with the power
one or the depth of this which can be
thousand or so if that thousand time
steps then and so typically no then if W
is larger than bundles explosives W is
less than one this vanishes and so this
creates this well known problem of
exploding or vanishing gradients here
and so this is something which is
avoided by this lsdm units because here
the key point is know that this
basically has made one to itself because
it remains there until you unless you
want to change it this so just having
you know the self connection with weight
one basically allows you for these units
not to avoid this problem with this
exploring of vanishing gradients then
so we found out that we can apparently
capture no essential part of this
capability with something extremely
simple then which go sleep back to no
new facility so if you focus on look at
the brain atlas of the lnstitute the
report among many no fingerprints of
really no biological neurons the so
called adaptation index and so their
measure here no vendor in the case you
give to the neurons the simply a step
current then for certain amount of time
then actually most neurons don't just
know fire then at a constant rate as no
simple neural models nor leak
integrating fine neurons would predict
but typically many of them will have a
kind of a rate which slows down then and
so therefore this measure here no looks
at the interspike interval n plus 1 and
compares it with a preceding interspike
interval so therefore I could for
example if this quotient has the if
they're double you know this interspike
interval this quotient here has the
value 1 third then right it's yeah so
this is two times as larger this one and
so this is so one third here is not the
value of this if though the interspike
intervals double here from spike - spike
them and in this Ellen Institute
database you see then they have measured
this adaptation indices which record no
measure like this and so this case of no
the doubling of interspike interval
would be here at the level of point
three point three then and you see no
they quite a number of neurons also
which have even higher adaptation index
so these are simply profiles of I think
150 or so neurons actually from the
human cortex which happened to be in
their database and it gives us a deer so
this are the neurons here know which
have this adaptation index 0 which have
no adaptation then and so there is a
large fraction of them maybe 50 or 60
percent and then you see other nodes
which have the spread of this adaptation
time constants so even wants to model
this neuron selection literature most of
the standard no modeling approaches
she covets neurons and adaptive
exponential fire nodes can be adjusted
to this we wanted to have you know
extremely simple model for this just
this adaptation effect and so therefore
behavior firing threshold for neurons I
call it be trained or like the bias of
the new NJ which consists of a constant
value and then something BJ of T which
is time dependent and so it's time when
this neuron fire so then this set J is
the spike trend binary spike trainer of
this same known J whenever it fires now
this no component is non zero and
otherwise no alpha J is something
between zero and one otherwise no this
the case then so therefore now whenever
this neuron fires maybe few spikes no
this goes up and then it the case then
if there's no firing and then if there's
a firing it goes up again and so on then
so it's just no extremely simple model
for an adaptive neuron then and it turns
out no that even includes this adapting
neurons in this network of spiking
neurons then when has nice
functionalities in particular also I
want to point out here from the
technical perspective one can actually
also apply back propagation through time
to this network of spiking neurons then
so this is actually something which has
been known now for a few years that you
know back propagation through time works
quite well through four networks of
spiking neurons so this was from the
benzio group and this was this IBM group
and they have proposed a very simple
solution if you have a spike then then
you have your step function which
basically decides whether they will be
posting uptick potential and other
neurons or not and so here no you don't
have a derivative here but if you simply
no you see absolute derivative which
goes up and down then it turns out that
pepra Gatien through time works quite
well then we had no he made one change
to the usual way it turns out no it's
actually good to have the amplitude of
the sula derivative less than one so
this is a technical aspect
then in principle it turns out no that
when applied this back propagation
through time also quite well even in the
presence of this adaptive firing
threshold because this is a similar
effect as for the lsdm units if no this
neuron is has a raised fine threshold so
it doesn't fire much so therefore you
have fewer of this kind of discontinuous
steps which cause always a little bit of
a kind of norm an arrow in the back
propagating error and then if the noodle
is not firing you just have you know the
smooth equations then and so there you
can rewrite precisely compute know the
back propagating error
so therefore this gives now then the
basis for looking at now what we call
now LS and ends where L stands for
something no longer and time it's really
no suitable for doing computations on a
larger timescales also and this networks
consisting of a population of regular
spiking neurons which are non adapting
and another neuronal population neurons
which are adapting then and both gets
inputs and both gets output in so this
now introducing this adaptive neurons
was one step to increase the computation
power of network of spiking neurons the
other step was not to use now kind of
naive architecture like no complete
connectivity or random connectivity like
an illiquid but rather optimized this
architecture for range of computational
tasks and this turns out to be really
essential and so for optimizing now this
architecture together with no optimizing
know the weights or so we use this
methods that robot had sketched know
this morning then and then we come up
nor you know rather the networks which
you know kind of masu randomly connected
you can hardly see this one gets then
one can in principle program into this
rewiring algorithm any desired
sparseness of connectivity and then you
get particular no kind of connectivity
connection probabilities for this no
three populations of internal process
ignorant them so no one kind of standard
test for the computation power of lsdm
like networks artificial networks is to
do em nice but in a really weird way
then because you have you known em
descendant digit but you presented one
pixel at a time then so you simply have
a schedule where this pixel first goes
through the first row then to the second
row and so on and the gray value when it
hits then a non white pixel then the
gray value of this pixel is then kind of
given as input to the spiking network in
our case here in the form of a
population rate then so we have here
population in this case of eighty
neurons then and the foreign probability
of these encodes the gray value of this
pixel so if we see for example here now
this is the this is now the input of our
time over 800 milliseconds so one pixel
each millisecond and so then you just
first have this empty rows then you hit
here no the row where there are few non
white pixels then again no this is white
part and then a little bit later you
again go through here and so this is now
the thicker part here and so this is now
the way how this hand-written 3 is
encoded and presented to the network as
simply as a temporal pattern then is
this clear so this is not something now
be invented this is a standard 'nor
benchmark task and actually one can
argue it's a really stupid way of giving
handwritten digits to a neural network
but on the other hand if you really know
look at how the brain actually gets
visual input it's actually also maybe
have capture something which is
interesting because even if you look at
a static image then you you're doing a
scan then right now your fixation point
no moves around then so in the end even
the static image is presented to a brain
as a time series then right so it's not
the certificate I'm serious but it's a
kind of
picture dependent no attention dependent
time series but it the friend also gets
visual input in for static images as a
time series is effect but here at the
moment we were just not interested in
exploring know the computation power of
this networks there and so this is now
here they know the adaptive neurons here
this earth is excited to inhibitory
neuron networks and so these are now
this frying threshold you see no they're
kind of moving up then as soon as
there's some activity in in some how to
understand Bay so the output here was
encoded by a softmax here then and one
CC&R the kind of the time cause of this
different output so there are nine
different possible digits then and so we
saw here initially no this network
considered various options what it might
see so initially thought maybe it saw
two which makes sense no as long as you
see only this part it looks like a two
later it thought maybe it's a six when
it got to see this then and then only at
the very end we kind of EQ the this
network to give now a final output then
it actually converged here no to the
right to the three then Sylvan takes it
as statistics of performance of
different networks so this is shown here
then now the test accuracy and so here
the red ones artificial neural networks
and so if you don't have Alice TM units
no it's not very impressive performance
lsdm networks get no without so much
fine-tuning no here to 95 or 96 then and
now the interesting point is know that
no record and the spike in neural
networks are even worse then notice
vanilla no artificial recurrent networks
but now the LS and n version gets even
over the kind of a stereotypical
architecture to high value and if you
include this rewiring then into the
learning algorithm then the can reach
here know about the same performance
level as lsdm units and so this was for
me something which I found surprising
now I haven't seen so far any way of
approaching the computing capability of
lsdm
networks with spike in neurons then one
other aspect nowhere LSM networks really
no play a prominent role is virtually
all recent work in machine learning on
learning to learn really no considered
in the inner loop lsdm networks then
also know the work of this mud but
Finnick reported no use this LS m units
in the inner loop then and so therefore
we wondered note about extent now we can
apply in a similar learning to learn
paradigms not to networks of spiking
neurons them and I was always interested
in this learning to learn aspect because
I have the feeling that when we are
training an artificial neural network
say on image net we're doing something
very different from what prodigy does to
enabling a brain to recognize images
then because no a no there's apparently
quite a bit of innate knowledge from
evolution in the design of the visual
system in the brain and then before now
the brain gets to see no image net that
I said it has learned lots of things no
like as a baby it's that it may be
recognized in the face of the mother and
maybe some other important things and
slowly know it has been expanding over
time to learn more and more complex
visual recognition tasks then so it it
was not really one learning face know
where all the visual object recognition
capability was built up but it was a
stepwise process a curriculum and I
think it would be very nice if you could
understand know these advantages of
these mechanisms and then also know use
them know to both know to enhance our
standing our sending of learning and
para signal networks but also use them
to know create better learning
algorithms for artificial no spike in
neural networks say in some spike based
hardware and then I think you most of
you may have heard of the know this
ideas Navi of 10 Bob and others in
cognitive science have pointed out in
that no
make use of this transfer knowledge or
innate knowledge probably no one has
though
these networks need to have a certain
it's abstract knowledge level then and I
find it's no really exciting the
research problem no how networks
artificial neural networks or to spike
neural networks can actually express
abstract knowledge how do you program
abstract knowledge into network how can
it apply this abstract knowledge to any
concrete computational tasks then and so
I think our hope is that by looking at
this learning tool and paradigm we can
make progress in our standing of these
problems for networks of spike in
neurons and so there has been quite a
bit of work on learning to learn
actually going back several decades but
I have not know seen work so if I apply
to network of spiking neurons and so we
were curious to explore this so before
so there are some concrete results I
would just want to remind you of no kind
of a theoretical framework here that in
principle not learning to learn means
you have two learning algorithms now
working in parallel then an outer loop
which is typically more an optimization
algorithm and you can think of know this
mimicking evolution there and the inner
loop which mimics then the learning for
the concrete current tasks then and the
standard setup is that you don't have a
single learning task but you have a
large general infinite family of
learning tasks so maybe think of all the
possible learning tasks which a
particular neural network is likely to
encounter during its lifetime this would
be introduced such a family F of
learning tasks so know roughly in this
outer loop learning or optimization
algorithm you know draw know various
snow tasks from this family you let this
network learn on this evaluate its
fitness and then depending on this
outcome you adapt certain hyper
parameters which are controlled only by
the upper loop and so what this hyper
parameters are this is something which
is up to the user of this model so
it's not no canonical and interpretation
of this standard interpretation of which
Matt Bert Vinick discussed and also I
will discuss this actually here the
really radical one name is that all the
synaptic weights of this network here
hyper parameters so therefore they're
controlled only by the outer loop I mean
now this network gets a certain task see
to learn it cannot change in synaptic
weights to learn this task see then it
has to use its kind of working memory in
its dynamics they're not truly no
accumulate results then and now provide
the basis for decisions there so here no
for this outer optimization so I don't
have scruples you know to apply back
propagation through time because this is
not claimed to be no a biological
optimization that we or I understand
then I think morally evolution no taking
place here then and so would of course
be nice not to really model evolution
but I think the parameters which are
controlled by gene regulation networks
are quite a park then so I'm missing
there really a nice formalization of
this optimization task from the
perspective of no evolution in biology
but also ban can in principle also use
then no gradient free methods like
evolution strategies which seem also to
work know reasonably well then and so
there's also one technically remark for
those who care about know this back
propagation versions then when the you
see an epic probation for the outer loop
then we actually we give this algorithm
access not only to the fitness but also
to the errors that it makes for a
particular input for this learning task
see then so therefore you can then know
know this outer loop can change its
hyper parameters to reduce the arrow
that this network makes them but this
has to be done in a careful way because
it's not the goal of the hyper
parameters to optimize Fitness for any
single learning task right it should
know for any even unseat unseen learning
task from this family
it should optimize its fitness and so
therefore typically and simply
implements this by accumulating pepra
gait and arrows over several tasks see
them before they're really applied then
so therefore you don't you avoid know
this Teddy gets over specialized for a
particular season right you try to
capture changes in synaptic strengths or
connections which are useful for generic
subsets of tasks from this family F then
so therefore hit the testing in this now
learning to learn paradigm is no
structure different from the usual setup
in machine learning so you all know in
machine learning you typically have
unlearning tasks and for testing you
draw new samples from this learning task
then but here testing even draws a new
learning tasks them right but still from
the same family of learning tasks and so
then this versa now in the paper from
Matz group nor two years ago this was
sketched in and also now in this more
recent a Nature Neuroscience paper you
can read this formalization so this was
just no here my introduction to this and
so as I mentioned now you have know
quite a bit of freedom in both no
defining the family f of tasks then and
also what the hyper parameters theta
should be which are controlled by the
outer loop and by playing around with
different families and choice of hype
around this one can get know quite a
number of interesting new insights about
spiking neural networks and I just want
to show you know two examples for what
what can one but achieves in this way
then but now they are only used this
kind of no default
assumption that all the synaptic
strengths and connections are controlled
by the outer loop that cannot be used
for learning a particular tasks them and
so this is something actually I found
quite now inspiring also no in
particular the work of Matt Burt Vinick
because it has become such a standard in
thirteen neuroscience that learning
takes place through a CDP then if
look at the data and extra Benten
neuroscience I don't really see strong
support for this that so look for
example at the work of from cosa who
studied know quite carefully how we're
different how a particular synapse
response to pre and postsynaptic pairing
a you see each synapse has its own kind
of villain or some of them don't change
at all some of them go up some of them
go down and particularly you have to
repeat no despairing at least ten times
to see any change then in typically to
see no kind of significant weight change
you have to pay at 80 times 100 times
and they don't really see the ground nor
when I learned a certain task know how
to open a bottle or so that these 80
different pairings of the same pre and
post up you frying in the same temple
distance takes place then so I think no
that third neuroscience possibly has run
little bit into kind of a blind le where
I'd really has no focus on this
assumption that a CDP is the most under
and most credible learning rule for
neural networks in the brain I don't see
this then and so therefore I find it no
quite convincing nor to also know this
ideas and that no there are other
temporal processes and adaptive
processes in the brain which take place
then which I usually ignored know in
these types of studies and so therefore
here in this case no when we now use
adapt ignorant no the adaptation of the
fine threads would be the one which no
already adapted and accumulate
statistical knowledge from the current
learning task then and so this seems to
be through work actually remarkable well
then and I think I see this only as a
kind of a first trial balloon in
principle there are dozens and more
longer-lasting temporal processes from
the timescale from seconds to minutes
and longer in biological neurons and
synapses there and I see no this
adapting foreign threat or just as one
kind of representative of this large set
of mechanisms there which can serve here
in a similar way then and I want to
discuss two demos and one is not very
similar to the demo with snow mud has no
disgust
in their papers and then everyone to go
back also to this who hider paper which
might opening also has mentioned and so
learning to learn from reports or meta
reinforcement learning as they call this
is now something where the fitness of
this network consists of accumulating
many rewards then and so therefore no
one uses here and outer loop and our
advantage active critic algorithm which
is no tuned version of policy gradient
in combination with deep learning for
optimizing fitness of the value function
and the policy then and so here is also
mat head nor described or they set up
here no the end gets as input the
current state I think yeah so this is
how if it gets as this is now this
network the spike in network now in this
talk in this no inner loop here and it
gets the current state of the agent as
input the reward at the previewing
proceeding time step also the excite the
proceeding time step and it outputs the
no kind of no particular action and
estimated value of this action in this
state and
so we know kind of took a simplified
version of maze navigation tasks which
map opening related to so we didn't want
to go into visual processing so we have
here just no discrete to two-dimensional
grid of four by five no cells then and
the rule was in one corner there was
always a goal then and then the agent
had hundred steps altogether to reach
this goal as often as it wanted then
could then
so whenever had reached the goal it was
reset to random other position in the
mace then and so initially it didn't
know anything about organization of this
or neighborhood relationship the cells
so each the current discrete position
the grid cell admitted voice was given
in one hot encoding to the spike in
neural networks and it got the reward
one each time it reached then this go
then so this is now here another when
the and so this out here the training
episodes in the outer loop and we see
here we go here two hundred two hundred
fifty thousand episodes so this is
something also which I learned here it's
not enough not to consider no thousand
or so training episodes for the outer
loop and sees remarkable things
happening in this range even goes to a
few hundred thousand and the training
episodes in the outer loop then so here
early on when the network hadn't really
acquired nor any useful knowledge about
this task then you see it was started
here and it just no randomly bumped into
walls no each time and it goes outside
in just by sheer luck it found no here
they go then but when it was no setup
here in a particular state it also its
syllabus cruisin around it didn't
directly go here then so therefore it
got only know a few accumulated rewards
so this year measures no for this
networks
how many rewards they able together then
within this hundred steps then so this
is no twenty able to be close to optimal
if and thinks no these are five no steps
just to go down here then so after
training man sees actually
this network of spiky nodes in the inner
loop not just a few hundred I think two
hundred some-odd less than a spike in
neurons is quite good then so it started
out here it first looks whether the goal
is in this corner and then it looked
into this corner then this was the first
pass then to explore a ssin then it was
randomly reset to this one so you see it
goes on the shorted pass to this corner
when it was again reset here no it goes
straight to this corner
so what's easier that the spiking neural
networks in the loop in a loop had
something had learned something which is
for computer program I think not easy
but for I've never seen this in the
spike in neural network because you see
here after learning this network of
spiky nodes has acquired really a clever
exploration strategy and then once it
has found about location of the goal is
it was able to apply this learned
knowledge now in many different
situations where it was randomly put
into other situations so it was
exploiting this learned knowledge then
and also it was controlling now really
behavior over know quite a number of
time steps then Zubin can also have in a
look now at the workings of this so this
is was the untrained Network you know
after very few training so it got a
report
yes so these are these inputs to the
network as I mentioned it gets the state
and the action and you know this is
actually I think signal it got no Rabat
0 then only if it gets a report and I
think it gets here one then and so you
see you know the activity of these
networks we don't quite know I can't see
any pattern there so now here now is now
this trend network which normally has
learnt this task very well so you see
it's time it gets a reward now this is
marked here by this line then and then
it's put into random position and it
moves in a straight to this gold it has
found then and so you see here no
certain patterns in the activity and
also now this firing thresholds are
moving in a particular base and I don't
understand how this network is doing
this and so this is something which I
find interesting and that now we have
now in our hands or in the computer
spike in neural networks which can
really perform tasks which I think we
cannot construct or I wouldn't be able
to construct the spike neural network by
hand to execute this task and we don't
even know how it's normally no handles
now this chakra how it uses now these
fine thresholds to accumulate knowledge
about maybe this one was actually I had
no remember the location of the goal
here no it was in the upper right corner
so but we don't know if this yet so this
is just something where we have not to
start to explore then reverse-engineer
these circuits which are optimized for a
particular learning task in this year
the tasks not to learn to navigate in
these mazes then and also not we get no
certain optimized architecture out of
this optimization in the outer loop then
we have to understand what aspects of
this architecture are essential for this
then and I think the program is
obviously to extract principles of the
functioning of these networks and then
put this principles by hand then into
new neural effects and see whether they
can learn then even faster there so I
think this is certain uncertainly
unsatisfactory that no we get this
networks only constructed by external
optimization processes the goal is to
really understand know by their work
this extended optimization process and
used in this recipe to build a network
snow in the end per hand and in a much
more clever way then but I think this is
not unlike no just goals of no
experimental neuroscientists right you
record from networks in the brain the
brain can do really no very complex
tasks we don't really know how this
exactly is happening so I think that the
main point voice is no substance no that
the one can part nor quite a bit of the
work of no the botany group also knows
the networks of spiking neurons and
exciter and hibbity neurons which is
quite nice because if and then wants to
relate know the emergent activity
encoding properties of the network to
recordings from the brain when Kenna we
went as excited and hibbity neurons can
compare this with firing of
corresponding cells in the brain whereas
lsdm units doesn't have really a kind of
activity which I would be able to relate
immediately north to to brain networks
because it really has no different type
of coding then so what they quickly also
discuss it is learning to learn from a
teacher how much time do I have actually
so yeah let's run quickly do this I
think this is something which is no
possibly a nice continuation of this
discussion which you yeah started
yesterday and Tim leave me crap know
describe maybe the problem
how can pelagic neurons not do something
back pop like then in Mencia no in yet
another hypothesis how this could happen
in biological networks of neurons there
so this is now something which is now
follows this inspiration of who Hyder
there be a principal now we want to kind
of induce this spiky neural networks in
the inner loop to be able to learn an
input-output behavior from supervise
from supervision there so it gets as
each time step it gets a new in this
case two numbers between 0 -1 and 1 then
no given in population coding and it's
supposed to give now the output of some
unknown artificial neural networks for
this input X 1 and X 2 then and so they
it has to make a guess then of course
the beginning has no idea about the
output but then at the next time step it
gets the kind of the correct output then
for the input at the preceding time step
so this delay of giving the target
output 1 step later was introduced by Ho
Qaeda simply to avoid cheating then
because if you gave no the input to this
network and the target output to this
network and you now I asked a network to
make a prediction of course it would
simply copy this teacher given input nor
and say this is now my prediction then
right so by giving this no correct value
the correct output always after this
network has made a prediction you avoid
this trivial cheating then but now so
you still it but it's still you
supervised learning in so far it gets
all the information only with a similar
with some time delay and in principle
you could compute now they are the
difference between the output they has
given for a certain input and the the
target output and can do with this error
whatever it would want to do then and
they
testing aspect is that no even takes a
closer look at the setup it has now the
freedom to reuse a very large set of
possible learning algorithms for solve
this problem where we would use back
prop here no to apply this year but you
see here the only way now this network
can produce here outputs is using its
internal activity dynamics so there only
local kind of no connections in this
network of course and by definition only
activity of neurons can be transmitted
there's no other way of doing back
propagation of errors no there's no
separate transmission line really for
errors in this network there and only no
connections existing in the networks can
be used
so therefore the network is forced to
use only its own dynamics there to do
whatever it wants to do as replacement
for peg probe on the other end Noel your
theoretical work had shown that just in
sometimes it's triple that synthesis is
in principle now if this would be in an
artificial neural network it could
approximate a large number of possible
learning rules then so and so therefore
the optimization of this network could
in principle now pick out of this infant
reservoir of possible learning rules for
such nonlinear a divisional network any
one which works best then
so this is now here know just the quick
demo before come to the end of know how
this spike in neural network solves this
learning task after no training in the
outer loop so here you see no this is
always one time step I think it was
chosen here 20 millisecond long where it
gets no two input numbers x1 and x2 in
population coding and then always the
target output value for the preceding
time step so therefore this is here now
a number of steps so in 15 steps it has
no 15 times going through this routine
it gets the input it has to produce and
guest output it gets the correct output
then so when measures here now the
quality of its output know this network
head after 15 such steps know almost
learned what this target network would
be then so basically it heads this
replacement of back propagation through
time was now in place after this 15
steps then which were in some sense
non-trivial because it was always given
random values as input right and so
therefore it could not just use a simple
lookup table or so to find out what is
now the target network then and and
again behave now a kind of reverse
engineering problems from this time
point on notice and this network has
clearly captured some insight it knew
what was this unknown target artificial
neural network which is were supposed to
emulate now in its input-output behavior
the question is where and how this
insight is encoded there so and see see
these are the activity of adapting
neurons and I don't see really anything
no no different from B before then but
here from this point on the information
about this target network must be in the
network then and will be starting now to
try to reverse-engineer what was this
kind of learning or ISM which no emerge
then in this spike in network nor
through this optimization process and
there's one hint new that it's not like
big prop because it has a certain
patient feature so we simply made an
extra mint they do
training we shown target networks with
four different target networks with four
different parameterizations here no more
often than the other random networks and
after then when we tested this now again
on this kind of more often
previously show networks it was
converging much faster to low error then
then for a new random network new random
parameterization of this so therefore it
had already know some priors extracted
from this long training face then so
this is something which I have not seen
in impact propagation Network so
therefore apparently in this network is
not implementing some type of patient
algorithm there so coming to the end so
I think now that we we're seeing now
really an early jump in the computing
and learning capability of spiking
neural networks recurrent spiking neural
networks where the reach and some
aspects know the capabilities of lsdm
networks we don't know yet now for more
difficult tasks now how father they can
go and how well they're compared with
lsdm networks so this is work for the
next year but also be seen adjust now
practically deep learning has become now
a tool for producing computation
powerful spike neural networks and
particularly cardinal networks so one
usually things not deep learning is
something but only deals with
feed-forward networks right here the
aiming at producing computationally
powerful recurrent neural networks and
we see very well that deep learning
methods aspect propagation so time is a
powerful tool to do this right and the
link is obviously this unrolling of this
recurrent network into a deep
feed-forward networks just for the
purpose of applying back propagation
here then so then I think now we see
that no this is very nice in a
relationship which might but winning had
sketched between their learning to learn
results and no brain data can now be
carried out also on the lab
of neurophysiology that we can now try
to relate also emerge inferring patterns
in the network which emerges to his
optimization which recordings from
corresponding brain areas one else
aspect which I find interesting in here
that no be set it up in the baby are
this networks the spike networks always
had to come up very fast with an action
or so in the report based learning tasks
so therefore most of the computationally
is carried out gorilla with single
spikes or spike patterns it doesn't
really fall back into a treble no
computation with rate patterns and I
think this is something very particular
need more kind of a paradigms for how
this can take place then it's very hard
to construct behind no spike in neural
network this really uses coding with
single spikes particular also know this
works also know this results if we put
noise into the network and then it's
particularly difficult to carry out no
powerful computation with single spikes
then then we see also that if we wonder
about how the brain learns no nonlinear
input-output behaviors that is a whole
new range of possible learning rules not
just no variations of backprop but also
no simply this learning arizim which
will emerge through this optimization
processes which rely simply on dynamic
processes within this network which are
there or they in it anyway then and so
then I think I see an very nice no
convergent kind of joint activity with
work in computational science in really
in advancing the art of reverse
engineering than anything here one has
actually one advantage or what
experimental neuroscience because we can
carry out even more experiments with
this no network of spiking neurons which
are produced in an in silico and on the
other hand will be certainly make use of
all these methods which have been
developed or the in neuroscience for the
same reverse engineering tasks then so
this was all
[Applause]
I think but they're gonna be we had
tested this for this last extra mint
Nevada supervised learning we had put
noise in there and it still work then so
I think now this networks cannot
typically get too much snow capability
from being deterministic because when
they learn something there's any very
kind of the unpredictable bit inputs
come in there so so there they have to
be able to deal with no
non-deterministic scenarios otherwise
they couldn't deal with this learning
task but what surely has to find out
what is the level of noise internal
noise which I can tolerate as I
mentioned we have carried out this
experiment also with noise in the
network so that we're kind of simply
just from this internal noise if you see
spike rusta for the same inputs no it's
hard to see that they're the same then
so kind of know quite a bit of noise
then and certainly it's something one
has to explore they're really new no
base of doing noise but no spike based
computation in noise environment in
noisy Network right so I think that we
should expect that we get some new ideas
from this approach then it's something
it's like something no baby probably
will do that so far we have put them
kind of know a little bit know like
inspired by this lnstitute data and a
summer spread of this time constants
which are in the right range then and
it's not quite cleaner we have seen also
kind of passing paces where we knew that
no working memory had to last nor for
say you know eight second in some of the
tasks which I didn't show and we put in
adaptation time concert which acted on a
faster time scale and they were still be
able to solve this fast and so I think
this is at the moment also know
something unknown to me at least
what exactly is optimal relation
between this adaptation time constants
and the working memory lengths which are
required for task them I'm not sure
whether we tested this to reduce them to
zero yeah I think it would be an
interesting experiment yeah but I would
guess no but you you would need them but
because I think the problem is also if
you use is adapting neurons for
computation no in some sense they're
rather unreliable computational units
right because if you use them a lot like
make it inspire fire off and suddenly
they became very reluctant to fire again
then right so but it's certainly
something to merge to find out then and
possibly no get at least hypotheses
about the biological effect that you
have both adapting and non adaptive
neurons and I have not actually seen
also in rural science maybe you know
some kind of really ideas no why
adaptive neurons early not increased no
the capabilities of the network I think
it has been usually no viewed more as a
nuisance than from the perspective of
modeling when suddenly C is here no
there really may again know quite a bit
of no computation power namely
essentially working memory capabilities
for the network yes I mentioned
sometimes we see also shorter time
scales sufficient but then also I think
it's something of by hand I wouldn't be
able to really construct the circuit
with adaptive non-story carry out a
working memory tasks and because you see
it's tricky actually to read out know
the content of the working memory right
because they're kind of Express their
memory by not firing which is actually
something which is smart probably from
the perspective of energy efficiency
right rather than expressing memory by
persistent firing now why not use non
firing then right but it's non-trivial
not to read it out then because probably
have to try in are harder and harder
until it it fires in the end and then
you in
way you can sample about the firing
threshold was for this for this neuron
then
I'm thinking of work of great hasslein
at Princeton whose proposed that there's
a gradient across the neocortex human
neocortex in terms of the time scales on
which computation is focused the width
of the temporal window of integration
and so I'm wondering what the empirical
data says about I don't know much about
about these kinds of adaptation effects
to is there evidence that in fact the
kinds of adaptation effects you're
building in your model here the time
constants on those vary across the
cortex like a mouse we haven't looked at
this data in lnstitute baseness so I
think I guess now that data from human
parameter cells a little bit not
accidentally simple then because now
these were from clinical kind of
applications and it's it's smallish then
but certainly this would be known an
interesting hypothesis to test right
know that in those areas we think
working memory it takes place like
prefrontal cortex that you find longer
adaptation time constant and then
actually also know the other interesting
time constant right we also know we know
that some neurons get more excitable
after being active than right we also
need to understand this in the
simulations this turns out to be more
brittle process because you can easily
over get the network overexcited if it
has too much memory stored then right so
but it happens in the brain but probably
some control really by inhibitor
processes which avoid this over boiling
of the network activities so we need to
understand not the use of these types of
neurons nor for computations
yeah and so yeah we planned it for 4:30
so maybe we should not delayed until
4:40 and then also know Fred summer is
then moderating this discussion you want
to say something now already or so so we
decided that we might actually stream
the discussion so is anyone would anyone
anticipated paid to be less lively in
the discussion if you use stream it
so if not then I would say get stream it
[Applause]